Patrick Cohen
Patrick Cohen colon retrouve dans cet
amour côté de anne-Élisabeth Lemoine
les animaux à manger
un petit peu l'inverse
samedi
à Lille et à Paris ou à Paris d'abord et
à Lille
et avec le message chaque rencontre
cet ordinateur que vous branchez au
clavier vous coiffez cette paire de
lunettes et là qu'est-ce qui se passe et
bien vont être projetés dans votre champ
de vision non pas un mais deux trois
quatre dix écrans à la demande en
réalité augmentée dans votre champ de
vision donc vous pouvez avoir envoyer
plus les gens alors si vous voyez aussi
les gens vous voyez les gens et vous
avez enfin si vous voulez dans votre
champ de vision des écrans virtuels
c'est quand c'est des robots bipède bah
regardez et là ça marche un petit peu
moins bien alors
en plus il y a les Runner créateurs qui
sont derrière pour éviter de quand ils
tombent de les rattraper il hésite alors
on accéléré l'image parce qu'il a
vraiment du mal et donc fini par Scooter
au bout d'un moment et pas marqué le but
et là c'est les meilleurs c'est ceux qui
ont été en finale l'année dernière et
quand on prend même les plus
perfectionnés regardez ça plonge tout
seul ça simule défaut
mais regardez le plus intéressant c'est
ça c'est la personne qui filme dans le
public ou le militant s'est pris un coup
de grue on appelle ça ah oui c'est la
caméra qui est censée voilà c'est le un
des cadreur qui a fait en sorte que qui
dégage exprès il a fait exprès mais
après ils sont fait bien évacuer
ça fait très mal ça fait très très mal
je vous confie
là ce sont des petits robots mais qui
courent et qui ont une véritable
stratégie de jeu d'envoyer ils sont
capables de se déplacer courir de de
d'avoir une stratégie d'attaque une
stratégie de défense oui c'est un jeu
one note one comme on dit regardez ils
sont capables ils se met en contre hop
il veut lui faire un petit pont il a pas
réussi à faire le petit pont donc ça se
commence à se regarder quand même hein
c'est assez amusant ils sont un peu
maladroit mais c'est assez amusant et
comparé à un petit un match vous savez
les matchs de D2 qu'on a parfois le
week-end ça se laisse regarder il y a
déjà quelques joueurs qui se sont pleins
de la qualité des balles est-ce que toi
tu l'as ressenti aussi sur les ridicule
c'est ridicule on joue avec des balles
qui grossissent au bout de 2 secondes
les balles neuves elle a dur pendant
même pas un jeu c'est ridicule les
balles sont vraiment nuls après c'est
pas une raison pour laquelle j'ai perdu
tout le monde joue avec les mêmes balles
je dis simplement que si on va avoir du
beau spectacle et voilà c'est c'est pas
avec ces balles là qu'il faut jouer au
tennis là c'est c'est les balles où on
peut pas attaquer où on peut pas avancer
ça fait 40 ans qu'un Français n'a pas
gagné le tournoi quand Yannick Noah a
gagné la finale de Roland-Garros je
portais des couches moi j'avais un an et
je pense que vu le niveau du des
tennisman français la prochaine fois
qu'un compatriote remportera le tournoi
j'aurais des couches aussi
les internautes sont invités à être le
plus précis possible et à joindre des
documents sans jamais révéler leur
identité grâce à un code secret ils
peuvent ensuite communiquer avec
l'administration fiscale si celle-ci a
besoin de plus de précisions lorsque ce
site a ouvert il y a deux ans beaucoup
ont dénoncé en Allemagne des méthodes
dignes de la Stasi l'ancienne police
politique de la RDA mais rien que l'an
dernier plus de 3000 dénonciations ont
été reçues
je suis ici à la Caisse nationale
d'allocations familiales accompagnée par
député et président
en Allemagne la fraude fiscale estimée à
plus de 50 milliards d'euros chaque
année mais selon cette association de
contribuables la fin de justifie pas les
moyens ça peut arriver qu'un conjoint
contrarié ou un associé dans une
entreprise donne des infos via ce
portail avec l'espoir de créer des
problèmes à la personne visée mais c'est
une autre histoire d'avoir des preuves
et c'est évidemment une dérive qu'on ne
souhaite pas on est là minimité
ça fait des jaloux voilà on a pas trop
trop le choix
celle-là ma dernière est vachement super
importante
il serait encore plus de 900 en profiter
une complémentaire de retraite très
avantageuse à laquelle les députés
européens ont pu souscrire jusqu'en 2009
parmi eux de nombreux Français des
anciens ministres comme Jack Lang ou
Michel halluari un ancien Premier
ministre Jean-Pierre Raffarin ou encore
Jean-Marie Le Pen
Bruno golnich fait partie des
bénéficiaires l'ancienne élu Front
national touche un peu plus de 4600
euros par mois de ce fond en plus de ces
autres retraites sur la vidéo
surveillance on aperçoit l'homme de 69
ans attendre patiemment pour déposer un
chèque mais devant lui une scène
anormale une personne au visage masquée
par son t-shirt glissamo à la banquière
il indique être armé et muni d'explosifs
j'ai vu à sa façon de parler qu'il était
irrité énervé il disait je ne veux
blesser personne
il semblait déprimé alors je me suis
approché de lui et je lui ai demandé
qu'est-ce qu'il ne va pas il a cotisé
pendant 25 ans et n'y voit rien de
choquant
c'est le système absolument de toutes
les caisses de retraite complémentaire
de France et de Navarre et d'Europe est
d'ailleurs le Parlement a créé cette ce
fond de pension en incitant très
vigoureusement les députés il y a des ré
vous n'avez pas de travail il m'a
répondu il n'y a rien dans cette ville
pour moi je veux juste aller en prison
Michael Hermès s'aperçoit alors qu'il
connaît l'agresseur il s'agit de son
ancien voisin et a mis de sa fille
Edouardo placia 43 ans
j'ai réussi à l'emmener dehors
et je lui ai fait un câlin il s'est mis
à pleurer et après waouh les policiers
sont arrivés mais il n'y avait pas de
sirène seulement les lumières des
gyrophares et ils lui ont dit
mettez-vous à terre
8 milliards de tonnes de déchets
plastiques accumulés depuis 1950 sur la
planète pour vous donner une échelle de
comparaison une tonne de plastique ça
équivaut au poids moyen d'une voiture le
calcul est donc vite fait ça fait
l'équivalent en plastique de 8 milliards
de voitures en 73 ans comme si la terre
était complètement recouverte d'une
pellicule d'un demi centimètre de
plastique c'est vraiment le tournis